[Music]
hello and welcome to this video this is
a video on an emu Indian line and this
is the line with 43 commonly known as
the Rubinstein variation let's get to
the starting position and this is the
move III this is one of the absolute
main lines III on move form the line
covered here and the classical Quincy to
basically share this status of being the
absolute main line um the movie three at
first doesn't look all that dangerous or
aggressive because white is locking in
his Bishop but if you look at this a
little bit more closely at the choice on
move form you will see that it is not
that easy to actually develop this
Bishop as we have seen for example in
the early Bishop g5 line the leningrad
variation this is often even a bit
premature as the bishop is not helping
wide on the Queen side when sometimes
needs to defend upon for example um you
can play Knight f3 of course but that is
the rogozin the qiam Knight of three
we transpose the movie 3 as mostly to
ideas it wants to speed up the kingside
development we have to absolutely see
that white is doing lots of things but
not working towards castling so this is
a move that helps to get cancelled it
should be three as a natural follow-up
develop the knight castle so it's a
rather logical in that regard the second
point of the move and this is really
commonly seen is to play the night to
eat you to help its friend on c3 and
being able to recapture without allowing
doubled pawns this approach is often
recommended in repertoire books there
are a couple of books recommend this
line for example by um corner for
Grandmaster income who released a
two-volume I think it's two or three
volumes on one d4 it's recommended by a
shun Dorf in a book or and by John
Watson there are a couple of books who
recommend this not because it's so great
actually but it is easier to learn than
the other lines now what is our choice
against III black as usual in the names
O is very flexible about this you can
play em gap basically every pawn move
that makes sense and you can Castle um
with our repertoire approach of usually
playing d5 the moves that mostly come
into a consideration are cancelling and
then playing d5 or playing d5
immediately the move d5 immediately
however has a drawback
after the media to d5 white can play a3
and after we take which is kind of um
yeah mandatory but should be seven is
very passive so we take and now we get
into a situation that you should compare
with this image variation with a three
or move form what we don't want in this
image is that in a situation like this
why it takes and then after pawn takes
we have a on structure like this where
white can play Bishop d3 and now
importantly
the 9:22 castle and play for f3 and f4
we don't want this scenario this is not
a completely terrible we are playing for
black well it's very demanding and not
optional for practical reasons white
scores very heavily in this kind of
lines so this is absolutely to be
avoided it's easily avoided because we
can castle first and then see what
happens this is also of course the most
flexible move as we don't commit to any
poor information yet now
if white plays a three now in comparison
we take and now of course not d5 that is
the thing that we wanted to avoid but
what we can do is we can play the move
Knight to c6 this is something that you
can easily compare with our
recommendation against the damage where
we would have the same position or could
reach the same position but with white
having played pawn to f3
instead of pawn to e3 so that right now
he could play a four in one goal this
basically means that this iam I'm sorry
about this painting this means that we
are basically having an improved version
as white in the long run wants to play a
form you had to build up a big center um
here white has tried some moves that we
should briefly check to get a feel for
what's going on um the most popular
birth is Bishop d3 quite logical yeah
preparing before immediately but what
has also tried Knight to f3 which
doesn't bother us all that much our play
now is pretty clear once we have the
knight here we want a dark squared
center with d6 95 and maybe get an idea
sometimes with a knight coming here to
put pressure on the pond so here D 6 and
D 5 is a very logical way to play after
castling we have a good range of setups
and somewhat uncommon one but in this
particular case very promising
is Bishop g4 anticipating that that
night might move and then we can trade a
minor piece something like this here
looks very okay in fact with the bishop
being on b2 or I mean you can argue
about the move Bishop b2 it wherever it
is placed for white it's never well
placed and we have clear idea so again
Knight to a5 maybe c5 we have targets
and white doesn't have a clear idea what
to do the move 90 of three looks
completely harmless to me Knight II -
looks a little bit better the idea would
be to bring this to g3 and then push it
for but we are definitely in good shape
here we could play with E 5 or
alternatively as we know that the knight
will absolutely not help in defending
this pawn we can immediately play
against that week pawn so the strategy
well known from this image is pretty
strong here after eform we should be
aware that white has the potential idea
to play Bishop g5 this is something that
oftentimes should be addressed and not
simply allowed here a good way to do it
is to simply retreat the knight
prophylactically this might at first
seem passive but they're armed
this is not such an easy assessment to
make the knight also has active ideas it
can be good on d6 attack points and
opening up the F pawn to move can be
very relevant as we will see Bishop d3
Knight a5 we need to and now a good move
c5 we fix that weakness and plan to
increase the pressure against the pond
if white now pushes d5 we have a very
strong reply to that and we play f5 that
is very nice it it really looks like a
very sharp move and it's difficult to
play this
yeah like make it up over the board
knowing the idea helps enormously yep in
some cases we even have the better play
immediately for example if Y takes only
six this is a very strong reply yeah we
attack the knight and white doesn't
really have a good way to go
where is the knight is supposed to go
yeah let's say it it goes back to have
one yeah we simply recapture and white
so placement of pieces is a mess yeah we
are currently looking at one two three
bad minor pieces and this pawn is
extremely weak so wide a fter f5 should
definitely capture this pawn after which
we take d5 that was the idea and after
this sequence we retain a very good game
the pawn f5 cannot be kept for example
after castles we take it and if anything
those pawns look weak I think we even
have good alternatives along the way and
to play with with this Bishop a6 and 985
is very natural and well known from the
same ish white will however most of the
time play Bishop d3 that is most natural
and we play e5 it is some important to
see this was a free preview of our
entire one d4 course based on the
nimzo-indian and rogozin available on
chess about calm thanks for watching and
see you soon
[Music]